it started we'd like to take this
opportunity to welcome everybody to the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies and to the 19th
annual is TF conference we're so pleased
that so many people are gathered here to
discuss this important topic it's of
great interest to us it's we'll be
focusing on the intersection of food and
forests in the tropics and we have
guests from as far away as Nepal on
Australia and we were very honored that
they have traveled such great distances
to be here and importantly I would like
to thank everybody who's put a big
effort into organizing this conference
as well as the people who have come to
participate and before we start I would
just like to make a few announcements
with regard to the schedule and
logistics first of all we're excited to
announce it we're broadcasting live for
the first time this year and please let
your colleagues know if they couldn't
come that they can watch the conference
online and it will also be posted
afterwards and if your twitter user our
hashtag is pound ICF 2013 it's over
there and tonight the keynote speech
will be followed by a reception which
will take place on this floor at the
opposite side of the building tomorrow
the conference will begin with breakfast
at eight thirty and the first panel will
commence at 9am for more specifics on
the agenda please refer to your programs
and if you have any other questions you
can find an is CF member I don't know
Ellen's telling me oh I'm gonna get
there and you'll find a green tag on the
is CF members badges and so you know to
ask them questions and there's also a
photo contest going on in conjunction
with the conference so please cast a
vote for your top three favorite photos
you'll find those hung outside as well
and as Ellen was telling me we would
like to make the impact of this event as
small as possible so please try to pay
attention to what you can and cannot
compost and recycle for composting we
have special stands with green sacks and
that's where you can place compostable
materials so everything but meat and
cheese for the most part can go in there
and even the plates silverware and cups
are compostable so please also put
goes in there so that's all I'm going to
say for now because I'm going to let
Dean crane introduce the conference and
the keynote speaker so thank you all for
being here and I hope you enjoy the
conference so my name is Peter crank
dean of the school of Forestry and
environmental studies here at Yale it's
a great pleasure to welcome you all here
for this 19th conference of the
international society of tropical
foresters and there this conference is
put on entirely by our students julia
photo right and Karen Peterson and her
team with the support of the school
including the efforts of many staff but
also generous support from from several
sources the the new york botanical
garden and FES common fund the tropical
Resources Institute here in the school
sac here in the school the old climate
and energy institute and the Council on
Southeast Asian Studies and Gary dunning
is also here from the forest dialogue
and he'll be running a workshop on
facilitating multi-stakeholder dialogues
over the course the weekend before I go
ahead and introduce our keynote speaker
I'd also like to acknowledge a couple of
other guests who are either here or
we'll be here over the over the course
of the weekend dr. Rajesh Thadani from
the center for environment development
and research in India and an alum of
this school is here hope you have an
opportunity to interact with him also
professor SP Singh one of the foremost
authorities on Himalayan forests and it
would be great to take the opportunity
while professor Singh is here to to
interact with him in a very important
book on Himalayan forests and I hope at
some point over the weekend that Amy
Vetter who's our Dorothy McCluskey
visiting fellow this semester and well
known for her work on a wide variety of
topics but particularly the mountain
gorillas in Rwanda will also be here I'd
also like to welcome in advance
dr. Anna herfurth who will be giving an
introductory talk to the conference on
tomorrow morning on the global movement
on food security and nutrition agenda
joining forces with conservation through
forestry and dr. hurt for this very
experienced in that area and I'll get
this conference off to a great start
tomorrow so finally now to to our
special guest Francis see more who's
currently senior advisor to the david
and lucile packard foundation and from
2006 to 2012 served as director general
of the Center for International
Forrester Research sigh for an
international organization headquartered
in Indonesia Francis led the development
of a new strategy for sy for guided the
launch of the CGI our research program
on forest trees and agroforestry and
contributed to many of ciphers programs
and publications on forests and and
climate change prior to her time at sea
for Francis was the founding director of
the institutions and governance program
at WRI the World Resources Institute and
also served as director of development
assistance policy at WWF in DC she spent
five years in Indonesia with the Ford
Foundation to focusing on community
forestry and human rights and Frances is
a great pleasure to have you here this
evening thank you for coming please join
me in welcoming our keynote speaker
Francis Seymour to kick off this year's
ASDF conference
well thanks Dean crane for that overly
kind introduction and thanks to the
members of the student committee that
organized this conference that you've
done such a great job on as some of you
may have heard I had a bit of an arduous
journey to get here today from
Washington and as a result this address
is not quite as polished as it might
have been if my plane hadn't been
delayed and a few other things but in
fact I think it's time to confess that
my arrival here in New Haven is in fact
30 years late when I was applying to
graduate schools one of my top choices
was the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies now I was lucky to
be admitted here as well as to the
public policy school at Princeton and
not wanting to have to choose between
these two wonderful options I proposed a
joint degree Princeton was up for it but
Yale wasn't so I went to Princeton and
as a result I've been an impostor in
forestry world ever since and so I have
to wear this color wherever I go to sort
of try to pass as somebody with forestry
credentials anyway I really appreciate
your giving me a second chance to join
the school of Forestry environmental
studies if only for a day by way of
explaining why i'm not using powerpoint
i should also mention that my father
attended the Divinity School just up the
hill back in the 1940s for several years
he went on to preach a sermon every
Sunday morning for 40 years and never
used PowerPoint so I figure I can do
without it as well now to the business
at hand the theme of this conference
being watched this afternoon is forests
and food security cultivating resilient
landscapes and I congratulate the
committee for choosing such a timely and
important topic and especially pleased
to have been asked to give this opening
talk because at this stage in the
Proceedings it seems much more
appropriate to raise questions and pose
dilemmas
and then leave it to you guys to answer
those questions and resolve those
dilemmas over the course of the
conference so my job is the easy one so
over the next 40 minutes or so let me
pose three questions and three quandary
that I suspect will be recurrent themes
in your discussions over the next few
days and my perspective is not one from
academia but from someone who spent the
last six years working at the
intersection between international
forestry world and international
agriculture world from a base in
Indonesia and my objective is to help
you think through the relevance of this
conference to the policies and indeed
the politics that characterize the
activities of those two worlds so the
first question to tackle is why is food
forests and food security and important
topic my answer that question is that
it's important because most people still
think that there's a zero-sum trade-off
between protecting forests on the one
hand and achieving food security on the
other or they believe that all we have
to do to avoid those trade-offs is
simply to intensify agricultural
production now those of us who inhabit
forestry world sometimes forget that the
things that we take for granted aren't
very well known even among policymakers
much less among the general public and
if you don't know any better it makes
perfect sense when somebody says well
you know it's too bad about those
forests and those cute wildlife that you
environmentalists care so much about but
hey you know we've got all these poor
people to feed and we're just going to
have to sacrifice the forest to extend
cultivation to to feed a hungry world so
you know in that that understanding
there's no recognition of the many ways
that forests contribute to food security
both directly and indirectly which means
that the land use trade-off between
forests and agriculture and forests and
food is not in fact zero-sum and in fact
it's estimated that over the last 40
years well more than two-thirds of the
increase in agricultural production
the developing world has come from
intensification rather than opening up
previously uncultivated lands so
extensive occation doesn't seem like
that promising a strategy to feed the
world anyway but this trade-off framing
is favored by those whose interests are
served by perpetuating the outdated and
increasingly inaccurate myth that it is
poor people who are the main driver of
deforestation saying that that poor
people are a cause of deforestation is
in fact has in fact been attributed to
me by a NGO that purports to serve the
interests of poor people but in fact is
associated with with corporate interests
and a fabricated quote for me was posted
on their list serve as part of a
campaign to restrain efforts the effort
the commercial forest clearing that is
in fact responsible for a preponderance
of forest clearing today so in order to
refute that kind of information it's
really important for us to understand
and to be able to articulate the degree
to which the causality is actually the
other way around in other words not that
food insecurity is the main cause of
deforestation but rather that
deforestation can be an important
contributor to food insecurity now a
second myth that needs attention is that
is one that accepts the importance of
forest protection but assumes that all
we have to do is intensify agricultural
production in order to spare land for
forests but you know research conducted
by David comets and Errol dangle ssin
and others at sea for back in the 90s
showed that depending on relative prices
and access to markets increases in
yields can actually accelerate
deforestation because it increases the
profitability of bringing new lands
under cultivation so support for
agriculture intensification is of course
going to be necessary to feed the world
but it is certainly not sufficient and
has to be accompanied by changes in
markets and governance to protect
to restrain forest conversion and
protect for us or we could end up with
those unnecessary trade-offs after all
now the second question that I think all
of you are going to need to get clarity
on in your discussions are well what are
we talking about when we're talking
about for us in food security now I know
that the presentation entitled the
edible forest I love that title is
scheduled to go last but i would think
that it's actually an important point of
departure for a discussion about forests
and food security that is the foods
there directly sourced from forests or
trees so you know for example it's
estimated that bush meat provides as
much as eighty percent of the protein
and diets and some parts of the Congo
Basin and a colleague of mine at c4
known to many of us did a
back-of-the-envelope estimate that the
bush meat that's produced by the Congo
Basin forest is roughly on the same
order of magnitude annually as the beef
that's produced in the Amazon basis and
all Basin and all that without cutting
down any trees and we can also talk
about how wild fruits and nuts provide
important micronutrients otherwise
missing grain based diets we can talk
about how forests provide the wood fuels
necessary to cook foods and we got a
note that the availability of food from
the forest can be especially important
in times of crop failure or famine or to
particularly vulnerable groups such as
aids orphans so it's clear that such
foods can make a significant
contribution to particular aspects of
nutrition of particular groups of people
in particular places and at particular
times but I would argue that too much
emphasis on forest foods as the key link
between forests and food security is to
downplay the broader direct and introduc
indirect contributions of forests to
rural livelihoods as well as the food
security more broadly and it's great
that this conference is not falling into
that trap so what else do we need to
talk about when we talk about forests
and food security perhaps most obviously
but not always stated for some reason is
that forests are the setting for Sweden
agricultural systems
and so I'm really glad to see the paper
by Diane Russell at all being presented
in the program on Saturday because I
recently read an article that stated and
I'm quoting here oil palm plantations
store more carbon than any alternative
agricultural land use at all I can
figure is that the authors forgot that
swidden agriculture is an agricultural
land use that maintains a great deal of
carbon in the landscape we also need to
talk about forests as a source of cash
income as a mark ESN argued about three
decades ago food security is not just
about the availability of food but it's
about access to income with which to buy
food so in addition to talking about
foods sourced from forests and trees we
need to talk about income source from
forests and trees in a broader
livelihoods framework now research
conducted by c4 and a number of other
partners in the context of the poverty
and environment or network or the pen
project provides some useful analysis
PhD students participating the project
collected income data for more than
eight thousand households in villages in
and around forests and 25 countries to
determine the portion of income that
they got from forests over the course of
a year and they found that on average
about 23% of household income in such
communities was from forest products and
that was more than the average share
from agricultural crops and it's also
important to remember that that share of
the income that is the sheriff from
forests is likely to be particularly
important to women because women tend to
take the lead in the gathering
processing and trading of non-timber
forest products so we've established
that forests have an important link to
the food security of individuals to
households and communities that manage
them for wild food for swidden
agriculture and for income with which to
buy food but do we stop there certainly
not because it's becoming increasingly
clear that the fate of tropical forest
has implications for food security up to
including at the global level through
the mechanism of providing the forest
based ecosystem services that support
agricultural production at the farm
level forests and trees provide shade
and fodder for livestock help control
erosion and maintain soil fertility at
the landscape scale we know that forests
provide hydrological services regulating
water for irrigation provide pollen
services that support yields and habitat
for freshwater and coastal fisheries and
there's increasing evidence that forests
and fluids the climate at the
continental scale so I was really too
happy to see the presentation about
Brazil lungs to bread basket on the
program tomorrow because I think this is
a scale of analysis that needs a lot
more of attention just for example
there's a forthcoming paper in
atmospheric chemistry and physics that
advances a new theory that condensation
and evaporation drive the atmospheric
pressure gradients that in turn drive
wind and rainfall patterns which would
make the role of forests even more
important in climate regulation and of
course at the global scale there's
recently been lots of attention to the
role of force and mitigating climate
change through the function of carbon
storage and I feel like many of us have
been consumed by the red agenda for the
last several years before us are also
critical to global food security for the
role they play in storing the germplasm
in the form of wild relatives of
economically important crops that come
from forests and finally all of these
forests based ecosystems become more
important in the context of adaptation
to climate change where we need the
resilience of intact ecosystems and the
biodiversity that forests maintain and
as the panel the title of panel one
tomorrow suggests we need to think
beyond yields how forests and trees
contribute to resilient resilience but
in a meeting with students this
afternoon Jeff shout out to Jeff
reminded me that we also need to talk
about how we can contribute to the
resilience of forests and trees to
climate change so that they continue to
providing those adaptations services
okay now to the third question and these
are with increasing difficulty
okay whose food security are we talking
about to have a meaningful conversation
about forests and food security we need
to be clear about the scale of our
analysis both in terms of the geography
of production and the geography of
consumption or else we could easily end
up talking past each other okay I've
given you the brief inventory of all the
forests based ecosystem services
important to agriculture and with those
in mind one could easily exam imagine an
example of a local scale land-use change
converting forests to crops or mangroves
to fish ponds that could increase the
food security of the local farmers while
contributing to negative externalities
at the landscape continental or global
scales and conversely I think we could
each imagine a larger scale land-use
change converting for us to agriculture
that could displace and impair the
livelihoods of the local community in a
country well their food security while
leading to an overall increase in the
food security of a country or region or
recent migrants or even consumers on
another continent and it is this last
possibility I believe that is at the
heart of the controversies over the
so-called land grabs that proliferated
in the aftermath of the most recent food
spike food price spike and the
associated export bans on grains because
a number of countries that were
dependent on food imports made it their
business to start prospecting for pieces
of real estate around the tropics that
they could cultivate to secure their
direct access to food and what they
found was that forest areas were among
the softest targets for cutting deals
with national and local officials for
large tracts of available land now while
I hesitate to say anything about Borneo
within 50 miles of Michael dove I can't
help but bring up the particularly
complex examples of you know whose food
security that are unfolding in
kalimantan these days with the
incredibly rapid conversion of forests
and peat lands to oil palm cultivation
now it's true that much of that
development has been fraught with
conflict and some of it has been over
resisted by local communities but a
forthcoming paper by johanna clerk and
Espen esther Mwangi documents how some
diet communities in West Kalimantan are
choosing voluntarily to work with
companies to convert forest to oil palm
and even though they might not be
getting a very good deal in terms of
compensation or benefit sharing the
expected thousand dollars per month per
household is an offer too good to refuse
in light of really little current income
from the forest and arguably the palm
oil that they produce keeps prices lower
than they would otherwise be for the
consumers in Indonesia India and China
who use palm oil as a staple cooking oil
so whose food security but a third
possibility whether than the win lose
lose win is a lose-lose outcome from
land use change undertaken in the name
of food security the best example I know
of again comes from kalimantan and that
is the million hectare rice project in
Central Kalimantan as you may know rice
self-sufficiency has always been central
to Indonesian national politics and back
in the 1990s President Suharto decided
to shore up rice production capacity by
ordering the clearing and draining of a
million hectares of peat swamp forests
and unfortunately nobody with the
necessary knowledge of agronomy had the
necessary courage to tell him it
wouldn't work so now local communities
are left with a heavily disturbed
landscape while the rest of us are stuck
with a gift that keeps on giving the
organic matter in the peatlands which
can be up to 30 meters deep as it burns
and decomposes emits a globally
significant source of greenhouse gas
emissions which thereby threatens
everyone's food security clearly what
we're looking for is win wins ways to
increase agricultural production that
enhance local food security without
compromising or perhaps even enhancing
food security at other scales these
options include
good agroforestry and they include
shifting agricultural expansion to
already deforested lands which is an
obvious answer to many of the problems
related to oil palm expansion in
Indonesia right now and I'm delighted
that Jonah bush is going to be telling
you guys more about that tomorrow now
let me shift to the quandary quandary
number one how should we frame the
forests and food security issue when
communicating with various audiences the
way an issue is framed often determines
who's interested in the issue and the
kinds of politics and policies that are
brought to bear on solving it and those
in turn drive who benefits and who loses
so it's critical to get the framing
right and i'm sure the discussions to
take place at this conference will make
an important contribution to our
understanding of the implications of
various options as I hope I've made
clear there are a number of serious
misconceptions out there that need to be
refuted relating to the supposed trade
off relationship between forests and
food security the importance of
complimenting intensification with
market and governance reforms and the
many ways that forest contribute to food
security beyond just forest foods but I
have to tell you in my view I don't
think forestry world has done a very
good job in communicating across these
various issues so to provide just one
example I was both surprised and
disappointed a couple of years ago when
a group of forestry agencies got
together to do a joint press release on
the occasion of world food day and the
first draft of that press release
focused almost exclusively on forest
foods you know we could wish that it
were otherwise but talking about
caterpillars and mushrooms is just not
the way to get forests a seat at the
table when policymakers are talking
about global food security but it is a
quandary because our moral instincts
would lead us to focus on the food
security linkages that are most
important to the poorest and most
vulnerable community you know people who
are directly dependent on for us
but there's also another reason I'd say
and that is the unevenness of the
research basis that's necessary to
underpin making the broader case there's
a lot out there on the linkages between
forest biodiversity and food security
and indeed health at the local level on
linkages between and on the on one hand
and on linkages between forests climate
change and food security at the global
level just to cite two examples c4
contributed to a useful special issue of
international forestry review a couple
of years ago that highlighted the
linkages among forest biodiversity and
food security but the main center of
gravity was at the community and
household level and also recently Ruth
to freeze edited a special issue of the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences about reconciling the
imperatives of tropical food production
on the one hand and global climate
change mitigation on the other but I
sense that there's a missing middle of
empirical research on the ecosystem
services provided by forests to
agricultural production at landscape and
national scales not to mention the
continental scales and the growing
importance of those services to
adaptation to climate change I feel like
we all cite the same study about how
coffee yields decrease with distance
from the forest edge in Central America
due to the services of forest-based
pollinators and for some of us coffee is
a staple food let's just be clear so we
need more studies like that because it's
precisely those linkages that would be
of most interest to the national and
sub-national policymakers who were the
ones making the decisions about land use
allocations there are the ones who need
to understand why forests are important
to agricultural production so in
addition to thinking hard about the way
to talk about forests and food security
there's still a lot of research to be
done to back up the assertions that I've
been making with a lot of hand waving
with a more rigorous evidence base
quandary number two again with
increasing difficulty should we
dismantle the barriers between forestry
world and agriculture world and talk
only about landscapes now
this is a real dilemma the case for
integrating forestry and agriculture
across landscapes is abundantly clear
for both conceptual and practical
reasons we know that individual
households put together livelihood
strategies that combine info income from
forests agroforestry agricultural crops
livestock many other sources so for them
the boundary doesn't make any sense we
know that agroecosystems don't have
clear boundaries between forests and
cultivated areas and that landscape
mosaics might in fact be the best way to
achieve certain conservation objectives
such as agricultural biodiversity and we
know that the strict division between
systems for administering forest land
and agricultural land separately is an
artifact of particular cultural and
political preferences if you haven't
seen it I recommend a very useful
article by Nancy peluso and Peter van
der geest and it illuminates how the
crest the the creation of what they call
political forests in Southeast Asia was
in fact an instrument used by States to
distinguish between jungles as places
where insurgents took cover and
agricultural landscapes where the state
maintained control and it would
certainly make life easier for the world
agroforestry center if these artificial
agriculture and and and forestry
divisions will go away and the
discourses and policies and institutions
were based on landscapes pori craft has
been uncomfortably straddling that fence
between agriculture world and forestry
world since it was founded and has been
working to dismantle that fence ever
since and indeed there are some signs of
a shift towards a landscape approach
starting with the framing of this
conference I note that the second panel
of the conference is reconciling
interests at a landscape scale so a way
to do that is verging agriculture and
forestry and I can tell you that a
landscape approach is currently very
popular with our colleagues over at the
World Bank and the most recent
development that some of you may be
aware of was the decision
discontinued the tradition of having a
separate forest day at unfccc cups in
favor of combining forces with
agriculture and rural development day
with a vision of having a joint
landscape day or landscape weekend
instead but taxonomy matters in
bureaucracies so while embracing the
clear benefits of a landscape approach
we need to have our eyes wide open to
the risk that important things could be
lost if forests as a separate category
goes away those of you who have ever
been involved in an organizational
merger know that what usually happens is
that the unique identity and values of
the weaker partner are completely
eclipsed by those of the stronger
partner within about three years so
there's some risk that the forestry part
of the figurative landscape would be
politically and institutionally
overwhelmed by the agricultural part
before too long and I can tell you that
having led the one forestry center in
the 15 Center CGI our consortium of
international agricultural research
institutes it was always a struggle to
get what we considered to be a fair
share of funding and attention to our
agenda now last year I was a meeting at
a meeting of forestry sector donors and
they got into a discussion about the
importance of having a separate funding
category specifically designated for
forests and one representative of a
bilateral donor agency that will be
unnamed told a story about a long
internal agency discussion about whether
to reserve either three percent or five
percent of a big multi-million dollar
agriculture and natural resources
investment fund for forests and in the
end they decided that zero would be the
easiest and indeed when USAID organized
to create a new unit focused on food
security one of the consequences was
that c4 no longer received funding from
the CGI our allocation now fortunately
diane russell and her team were able to
find a way to get us funding from
another pot
money at USAID so not all was lost but
here's a case where a focus on food
security meant no focus on for us so the
quandary is how do we mainstream the
forest agenda into a broader landscape
approach to food security without having
it disappear altogether quadri number
three again this is this is the hardest
how do we design market and governance
mechanisms to protect forests that at
the same time respect local rights and
give weight to the legitimate food
security concerns at different scales
now this quandary is foreshadowed in the
theme of the third quandary of this
conference large scale governance and
small-scale farming and it's a set of
issues that Ben cashiers Littlefinger
knows more about than I will ever
understand but as I've learned more
about international efforts to
incentivize sustainable oil palm oil
production I'm increasingly aware of
just how hard it is to design global
governance and market mechanisms that
are sufficiently targeted so as to avoid
the type 1 and type 2 errors of
rewarding the bad guys on the one hand
or punishing the good guys on the other
so as an example many NGOs have invested
in working with the roundtable on
sustainable palm oil and I'm sure Gary
Dunning is going to have some useful
insights on such multi-stakeholder
processes in the workshop he's leading
tomorrow but it appears to me that in
this one the interests of many of the
participating companies and a sort of
least common denominator dynamic have
resulted in a certification system that
doesn't yet prevent certified companies
from continuing to DeForest on the one
hand and without making it especially
easy for smallholders to benefit on the
other jonah bush and i were at a forum a
few weeks back convened by an important
important consumer of palm oil that
wanted to make a commitment to sourcing
only certifiably sustainably produced
palm oil that did not constrain the
legitimate aspirations of smallholders
to improve their livelihoods and
unfortunately it seemed that we've got a
ways to go
that's really possible you know to make
such a commitment so there's a lot of
work to do now I said that I only had
three quand Ruiz but since we still have
extra time right I'm going to throw in
one more quandary as a bonus for extra
credit quadri number four given the
multiple challenges of mobilizing
forests for food security and the
urgency of doing so where do we focus
our efforts this question is important
whether you're a Yale student choosing a
career path whether you're a faculty
member choosing where to focus your
research agenda or a donor in the
position of allocating scarce funds to
forests and food security and the good
news I guess is that there are plenty of
challenges to choose from across all
disciplines and scales there are
technical challenges there are economic
issues there are governance challenges
and indeed there are political
challenges not to mention the
communications challenges that I've
mentioned earlier but it's certainly
good news that there's plenty of talent
in this room that can be applied to
overcoming those challenges but time is
short and money is tight so you've got
to choose wisely so I hope that the
discussions of this conference will help
us have a sense of priority among those
challenges as well as a sense of
opportunity now I usually in these
speeches by saying I look forward to
your questions but having provided the
questions and quad Ruiz to you this time
I get to say I look forward to your
answers thank you very much
on that note if anybody has answers
they'd like to give her or we'll take
questions too I think we have a few
minutes for that so just raise your hand
and I can bring you the mic no one has
answers mm-hmm ok ok we'll do questions
hi my name is Judy I graduated 2010 FES
and also School of Management and with
the work that I do with the indigenous
people in the Amazon that are cacao
growers now make their own chocolate
market it not only to affluent and
middle-class clients and Ecuador they
export to various continents well we've
researched and found is that people in
forest areas have an abundance of
natural resources they have no markets
in there near proximity that they can
market those products to for a high
price so they must package process and
somehow get it to urban locations that
will pay for these scarce resources now
how can we balance that out is the big
question but I do think that is one of
the answers to this concern with food
security that you may not have to sell
only to rich clients but at least a
location where the product is somewhat
more scarce so that you can provide for
the labor required to cultivate and
maintain these forest products in
sustainable production thank you I
really appreciate that I agree with you
that that's that's one of the answers
and you know back to this palm oil
example I mean one of the problems is
that even with this fairly low standard
of certification certified palm well
available only something like fifty
percent of the available certified palm
oil is being taken up by the market so
it's a huge job to be done to increase
the demand for you know environmentally
preferable project products just to take
up the demand much less to provide a
price premium or any kind of
preferential market access so yes the
market x
to market is huge
I'm not the most efficient way to do
this okay thank you so much for that
regarding your first quandary the need
for really rigorous research on
mechanisms of ecosystem services you've
listed our favorite paper and he also
listed the most commonly sort of
accepted ecosystem services if we had to
focus our efforts in a smart way which
services would you recommend that we
study mechanistically first is it
hydrological is it something more deal
with soil services is it with production
of given products do you have sort of a
personal sense on that you know this is
a something that should be done more
systematically rather than me talking
off the top of my head but since you've
asked me um i would say water services
needs more research in part because they
have been controversial in the past may
i don't know how many of you were aware
of the big controversy coming out of c-4
about you know forests and floods you
know deuce DeForest control floods or
not and i think there's more work to be
done and that's astonishingly you know
after all these years there still hasn't
been a lot of empirical research to
actually you know answer the questions
that were raised in that controversy and
given that pretty much everybody agrees
that the next big crisis is going to be
a global water scare at City crisis
everybody's going to be interested in in
water and so I think getting ahead of
that and having some good empirical
analysis to underpin the claims that we
make about forest being important as a
regulator of hydrological services has
got to be high on the list and I guess I
would just as a friendly amendment to
that not just like at the watershed
scale but this new stuff you know more
at the continental scale you know I am
this is completely under informed
because I don't really know Brazil but
it's striking to me that the sort of
attitude of Brazil towards international
forest protection efforts including red
has evolved in track with the increasing
scientific understanding of the
importance of the Amazon rainforest to
providing rainfall to the Brazilian
breadbasket I don't think that's a
kinetic coincidence it could be but I
think as national governments start to
understand that preserving forests is
important for preserving their own act
mestic agricultural productivity that
that is is a way to really see that this
is a win-win agenda not a zero-sum
trade-off so actually is more a comment
I'm I'm from Brazil and Brazil just
passed the forest code and is actually
the opposite because they have reduced
the size of the riparian forest that
protects the rivers so despite all the
efforts from the Brazilian Society of
Academy of the scientists and even I
don't Brazilian NGOs what the government
has done is to I don't know tomb to
reduce the riparian forest and just
taking an account the the rural rural
list or the soy producers or cattle
cattle ranchers and so it's kind of a
little bit challenging and one of my
question is I used to work in the
agricultural frontier where the soy is
expanding in one of our biggest
challenges is how to deal with the asian
market demand that is increasing very
much so which kind of policies or
private sector commitments like the
round table responsible soy or what kind
of any other instruments can we can we
try to develop or we can address to Rio
to address this challenge of for keeping
the forest in keeping the water at the
same time right um wait that was just
gonna be a comment ya know um yeah let
me let me just say one comment on your
comment and then then move to your
question um I know that the brazilian
forest code discussion is a very complex
one but i have to say in that context as
well as in the the context of the
indonesian moratorium on forest
exploitation which jon is going to talk
about tomorrow one can can can see those
in a way as an inevitable pushback from
interest that feel threatened by the red
agenda and to me that's a really
positive sign
because it shows that the red agenda
actually has some traction if people
feel threatened by it and since when has
forestry world ever threatened anybody
you know with real you know policy
change and so I think it's it you could
see it as a positive positive indicator
how to deal with growing global markets
for these commodities that that reduce
forest I mean I will out myself as
someone who had been a real skeptic
about the potential efficacy of
certification type you know voluntary
strategies back you know 20 years ago
when they were first like the Forest
Stewardship Council was first getting
off the ground because I was you know at
that time living in Indonesian it's like
well great you might be able to convince
European and North American consumers in
my lifetime that they need to
preferentially you know take certain
commodities but you know in other parts
of the world it's just not going to
happen a relevant time timeframe but I
was wrong because it turns out that you
don't have to convince every individual
consumer because so much of world trade
is mediated by these consumer facing
brands that are in fact global companies
and so either because they don't want
Greenpeace hanging out their windows or
they don't want don't have to invest in
segregated supply chains you can
actually move markets by targeting some
of these intermediary steps in the
supply chain and there's a whole
industry of non-governmental
organizations working on exactly that
opportunity right now and so in the
short run that is one way to attenuate
the the demand for unsustainably
produced commodities but over time you
know an emerging middle class and in
China or India or anywhere else is going
to become you know sensitive to some of
these same or is already becoming
sensitive to some of these same issues
and in fact completely different topic
but I've heard an amazing story about
how this campaign in China to get people
to not Nina to not prefer shark fin soup
has had amazing success in a very you
know short amount of time so I think we
need not be too pessimistic about what's
possible
now it's just a short comment about
research addressing landscapes I think
maybe write more than being a new item
on the agenda maybe the what's happening
now it's it starts to be a little bit
manged mainstream which it was not
before because I think there has been a
lot of research done about landscapes in
the very long time so what might be
required now is to connect that research
to the mainstream agenda to conservation
and sustainable development research but
there's a lot of thing done already i
think here but that's not to minimize
how hard it is given the entrenched
institutional structures that are that
divide agriculture and forestry that
don't always play well together at
various scales so yeah I agree with you
a lot of hey it's not like this is a new
idea or anything but i think the the
resilience of the divide shouldn't be
underestimated I Francis um I seen you
several times in bogor as a director
general of c4 so I would want to ask a
question after you step down whether or
not what's your view of Indonesia state
of forest particularly with its
commitments of greenhouse gas emission
reductions redd+ and also expanding
you're talking about the expansion of
palm oil Indonesia as well well I mean
it's it's always a very mixed and very
dynamic picture certainly it's been very
important to have a head of state and
I'd say the same in Brazil you know if
you had the head of state talking about
forests and the importance of forest
conversation that counts for a lot you
know and part of that is having the
Norwegian letter of intent you know a
billion dollars gets people's attention
even if it's kind of puny and the grand
scheme of things in Indonesia but you
know it's it's mobilized political
attention
at the national level and a discussion
about for us that has never happened
before and as I said in response to the
previous comment I think that even
though the moratorium as constructed was
quite disappointing in terms of how
limited it was you know not including
secondary forest for example the fact
that you know that discussion took place
and now there is a formal structure for
making forest maps transparently
available to the public which let's be
clear people have been working on that
for 30 years and never managed to get it
done but you know that happened within
the last year and a half has put into
place governance processes that over
time can only help make things better
the problem is is that the time scale is
is you know that the expansion of palm
oil is happening so quickly and the
timescale for building institutions to
rationally make land use allocation
decisions you know it's just it's going
to be slow and so the real key question
right now is you know what can for lack
of a better term people like us sort of
interested outsiders who want to be
helpful you know what can we do both to
help accelerate that institutional
development that's going to be necessary
to have a more rational you know
allocation of land so things like some
of the technology interventions that
help to map you know where the peat
lands are and where there might be
available land to divert you know
production onto from from out of the
peat lands and as well as helping to do
some of the market interventions that we
were talking about before you know
creating a demand for more sustainably
produced commodity so as to incentivize
companies to do the right thing but I
find some particular so it's a challenge
and is there's no guarantee it's going
to turn out right and you know we're
moving into a presidential election
season and you know sort of all bets are
off with it with that process but I see
reasons to be optimistic I mean you know
i was working in indonesia with the ford
foundation 25 years ago and at that time
you couldn't even talk about indigenous
peoples rights without being labeled a
subversive i mean there were just you
know you couldn't talk about illegal
logging or corruption these were just
you know taboo topics and so now to
fast-forward 25 years later where
there's open discussion like at the
highest levels of the Ministry of
Forestry about the possibility of
recognising indigenous peoples
it's plan oh you know it's just an
amazing you know progress so progress is
possible and I think some of the things
that we've been talking about here that
are going on will will help accelerate
that progress but you know jury's still
out dr. Seymour thank you very much for
being here to start this conference for
us it's a great honor for us to be able
to have this conversation with you my my
question is regarding when you were
mentioning the type of large-scale
research that we need to address these
landscape level ecosystem services that
forests provide for agriculture and it
made me think that some of the the
strongest most powerful research that we
find in the scientific community comes
from medical science and we would think
about the sheer volume of research that
comes out the medical scientific
community really blows us away here and
why is this possible it was partially
because it's funded in so much by the
drug industry so for us here in the
biological community perhaps it's time
for us to start thinking about different
sources and different avenues for the
type of research that we need to do so I
wouldn't call it selling out to the
agricultural industry but perhaps
leveraging the agriculture large-scale
agriculture is what our biological
community in our forest community needs
to start thinking about well I just
thank you for awarding me a doctorate
which I have not yet earned got one more
question probably before we wrap things
up and head over to the reception anyone
else we can take to thank you my name is
Anna her fourth and I'm coming here
mostly from the nutrition community
nutrition and agriculture and I really
appreciate being briefed on all these
issues from you probably things that
most people in this room know a lot
about but a lot of them are a bit
outside my typical relevant I really
appreciated the primer and you were
talking about the divides between
forestry and agriculture and in my work
usually I work with the World Bank in
fao
usually what I'm trying to do is is
reduce the divide between agriculture
and food security or agriculture and
nutrition even further so usually I
don't see Agriculture's necessarily
aiming to improve food security as their
primary goal and i was wondering from
your experience in your perspective how
often do agriculture investments or
programs or endeavors actually aim to do
something about conservation because
that would seem to be where forests
might fit in so the question is how
often do in agriculture sector
investments aim to do something about
conservation right you know I have to
say obviously there are they're
interesting things alone all over the
place but the part of agriculture world
that I've been intersecting with is
remarkably traditional and still thinks
about environmental issues as sort of
externalities it's like oh well there's
pollution from fertilizers and
pesticides that we kind of need to worry
about but not a sort of ecosystem based
integrated approach to agriculture and
forestry with with conservation
objectives so I would say it's still the
minority it's not it's not yet named
strained that's my impression there may
be others in the room who know the
universe better than I do but I
definitely an area for further
improvement although it's kind of
discouraging to hear you say that the
agriculture and nutrition silos
Argentina that too you'd think those
would have been closer and over here and
after you're done with the response we
invite you also head over to the
reception on the other side of this
floor thank you for the presentation
again and for being here it's great to
have you so you mentioned about um some
of the challenges that could like the
Big Brother in a way have with the
little brother do not like the
agriculture having more resources at
mountain mostly at the national level
we'll have a like sometimes a negative
impact in little brother forest
especially liked the arrangement and the
institutional arrangement in some
countries that the Agriculture Ministry
has a lot of resources compared to like
four
which is normally minimal in like
environmental ministry and so having
said that and you mentioning that that's
one of the risks that we can we need to
take it also comes as an opportunity and
maybe I would like you to address like
if this is like some of the
communication aspect that could be
really be strengthened of having more
like the solution of the Big Brother
helping the little brother and giving
more resources and sharing those
resources and to actually have a like
like a holistic vision in terms of the
landscape so is the challenge and based
on your experience more on like
different like very very narrow
efficient of those two sectors and if
actually is that a solution to to be
achieved soon to really like get some
resource out of the environmental mean
um from the agricultural music to be
shared is that because of the focus and
like terms of communication hasn't
really been address of of this benefits
of Environmental Services or is it or
does it go beyond um like what is the
challenge to really like avoid the
little butter like disappearing thank
you that's a tough one um I think it
again it comes back to the point I was
trying to make about the importance of
how problems are framed and so again
just to give a simple example when
President Yudhoyono made the commitment
to reduce Indonesia's greenhouse gas
emissions and this was like the first
developing country government to make a
voluntary commitment and it was going to
be you know reducing by help me Jonah
twenty-something percent without
international help and forty-one percent
you know with international health am
ambitious you know commitments to reduce
emissions and so then the next step was
to allocate those reductions like on a
ministry / ministry basis you know so
it's like okay transportation sector
your job is to reduce this much and
agriculture your job is this much in
forestry your job is that much and and
by dividing it up you know that sort of
reinforced those you know the silos
and didn't incentivize you know
collaboration and so I my instinct is
that there's got to be a way to frame
the problem you know or the solution in
the case of like providing ecosystem
services in a ways in a way that forces
collaboration and would make it in the
interest of an agriculture ministry for
example to share resources to those who
have the necessary expertise or
jurisdiction to reach that you know
solve that particular problem or reach
that particular objective so again it
comes back to framing I think I've set
up for now if we give one more round of
applause for Francis